it's hard to say in fictional Wonka
World whether creating five tickets to
your chocolate factory would be
something that we could predict would
cause kidnappings or mass hysteria or
stampedes or anything along those
[Music]
lines that Gambler from Paraguay made up
a phony ticket well there are so many
corporations that have contests right
all of our fast food chains other big
companies and everyone wants to
participate in contests so the idea of a
contest itself isn't illegal necessarily
I got to assume that on the back side of
the Wonka bar or somewhere in the fine
print somewhere there's all of the terms
and conditions apply and everything that
we would hear in commercials and the
fine print on our game pieces for Mass
contests and things along those lines I
can't see what it says in the bottom the
contract that Wonka makes the kids sign
is really interesting on two levels
first of all kids can't sign contracts
so just on its basic level he had the
five kids sign the contracts they're not
18 years old it's not enforcable done
that's the end of the analysis on that
part of it now as far as the length of
the contract goes if we had the adults
or the parents signing those contracts
the argument then is did they have a
chance to read it did they have a chance
to have legal counsel go over it with
them and advise them of all of the terms
and conditions of it and then it gets
smaller and smaller and smaller as we
get to the end and this is an
interesting area of contract law in our
country right now with the terms and
conditions that all of us just click
accept because we want to get to the
next page of the website so long
contracts that people just scroll
through and click accept at the end the
big companies are definitely trying to
enforce this and I believe Wonka would
try to enforce that but the arguments
there would be it's so long they didn't
have a chance to read it it was
impossible to read by the the time you
got to the bottom of the fine print
that's a pretty good argument as to why
the contract should be voided even if an
adult signed it you've ruined your
Watershed Wonka is polluted I think
Wonka's responsible for every single
bout of food poisoning that comes across
him from a legal Food Service standpoint
you almost have to Nuke that entire room
from orbit and just be done with it to
move forward I mean every single thing
that they touched wouldn't be able to be
touched by anybody else going forward so
I hope that that room was just a display
and that he disintegrated everything
afterward but knowing what happens with
the river and everything else it's
probably just all contaminated gross
disgusting handled food that is also
sitting out without Refrigeration or
without any sort of storage or anything
along those lines so we could see a
class action for all of those people we
could see liability for that or it could
be the handful of people who found out
after the fact that they were eating an
Augustus bar and then were traumatized
about it and didn't want to have a bar
that a 13-year-old swam
[Music]
in I will say that I am happy to argue
that the getting out of a verbal promise
with a 13-year-old pinky swear by
crossing your fingers absolutely get you
out of any contract that a 13-year-old
would enter into verbally I'm happy to
make that argument all day every day and
I would win because they're 13 and they
can't enter into a contract
anyway I don't know that we get to the
level of kidnapping with Oompa loomas
cuz there's an idea here that he gave
them asylum in some way shape or form
here in California I can't even hire a
legal intern uh without paying them and
compensating for their time unless
they're getting college credit we're not
allowed to have employees just for free
or for service or anything along those
lines so the idea a that the Ooma loomas
are getting room and board but not
getting compensated for their actual
time is a huge problem with labor laws
and everything else the first thing that
I can't quite get past when we do a
criminal analysis of the police raiding
Wonka's factory and questioning why
there's 200 oal loas there is the song
that they would sing I mean what is the
oal loopa song for the police are here
and we need to be
free but but they're going to ask
whether they're there against their will
or not against their will I mean it
certainly seems like they're happily
working in going through the process I
mean all joking aside it doesn't seem
like he's mistreating them or keeping
them there against their will the Oompa
Loompa Workforce would probably get an
amazing labor law class action attorney
to file them for not getting breaks not
getting time off not being paid
correctly and that would put Wonka out
of business
permanently
W this concept of attractive nuisance
means that somebody in a negligent way
put something that would encourage
someone to go into a dangerous area so
that's basically the entire Chocolate
Factory so if I'm the lawyer that's
suing Wonka I'm going to argue that they
didn't put up good signs they didn't put
up good railings that they didn't do
enough things to stop someone stupid
from going into a dangerous area and
that's the Ive nuisance law and that's
all of the liability issues that he
would have for creating a situation
where the kids could even jump in the
river without any stop or could get up
to the uh place where they lay the
golden eggs and fall through the shoot
the fact that he didn't put enough
railings and safety measures in place
would absolutely subject him to
liability for that they won't really be
burned in the furnace will they H so the
law about a a death in a business is is
homicide I mean it's unlawful death of
another of another person and so
typically we talk about them in two
different phases we talk about that
manslaughter versus murder murder is an
intentional killing with some sort of an
evil thought where manslaughter can be a
negligent act that ends up with someone
dying so when Wonka creates a situation
in his Factory that's unsafe or fails to
stop a kid from going into a dangerous
place or any of the things that happen
to these four other kids or they Charlie
and and Grandpa Joe had gotten stuck in
the fan and and had died all of that
would be an allegation of negligence
that resulted in a death of a person and
that's manslaughter it happens every
time they all become blueberries it is a
dark path to go down to suggest that
Wonka just let the nasty kids go into
those situations intentionally but if we
had some sort of uh I don't know Journal
text messages something along those
lines these these days where it
indicated that yeah I can't wait for her
to go down the shoot with the Golden
Goose and go to the incinerator because
she's been rude to me all day then yeah
that's a little bit more of an
intentional act at that point and
there's two different parts of the
analysis it's intentional and so that
might constitute malice but there's also
another legal principle where you create
such an inherent dangerous situation
with a complete Reckless disregard for
the lies of others that you can be
guilty of the higher levels of homicide
you can be guilty of murder so for
example if I fire a gun into a crowd I
might not be technically intending to
kill anybody but it's so reckless with a
complete Reckless disregard for life
that I will be charged with murder for
that so Wonka if he intended to kill off
each one of those first four kids uh
could be looking at some very serious
criminal charges so the factory is yours
Charlie you can move in immediately
legally speaking there's nothing that
stops someone from giving a company to a
kid we have people all across the
country and all throughout history that
give their businesses to their children
in some way a 13-year-old isn't going to
be running a company though a
13-year-old doesn't have legal capacity
of ownership of contract signing of all
of the other things that adults have so
if we were to apply this to today what
you would probably see as some sort of a
trustee someone who would be in charge
for purposes of uh making sure that the
company was well taken care of until
Charlie came of age I'm not exactly sure
what's going to happen so you think
about the glass elevator and you think
about Wonka's attitude about it and how
he's just delighting in the fact that
everyone's scared which is all fun in
games until you know what if Grandpa Joe
had a heart attack or something along
those lines because of the fear that he
was being placed under and there are
causes of action where people can sue
for intentional infliction of emotional
distress it's almost only seen in law
school exams I mean there are attorneys
that will sue for that it's almost a
joke in the legal Circle that this is
the thing that you Sue when you can't
find anything else sorry attorneys but
that's the reality of the situation if
you can't find anything else sue for
intentional infliction of emotional
distress but in that elevator Grandpa
Joe is absolutely scared out of his mind
and so is Charlie I would be less
worried about Charlie in that moment
because a kid can absorb more of that
adrenaline more of that fear but Grandpa
Joe was just laying in bed like the day
before just barely started walking again
and then we put him in Mortal fear for
his life thinking he's going to be
ripped to shreds I mean this is
potentially is this the first drone is
this the first you know privately owned
you know aircraft that goes up in the
air uh there are all kinds of
regulations for aircraft it means the
reason why we don't have flying cars yet
because we can't just have everybody
randomly just popping off into the air
so it's the least part of his problems
but sure he's also probably violated FAA
regulations on airspace use and
everything else I can't go on forever
and I don't really want to try I don't
think the Chocolate Factory goes out of
business I think that they pay out each
one of the families a significant amount
of money and not enough that it runs the
company out of business at all I think
that this is no no different than a
large corporation that has an issue has
a scandal has a damage it almost never
causes that big Corporation to go out of
business there's Insurance in place
there's money to pay off the the people
so that they're compensated in some way
for whatever damages they had I I think
about Violet and getting squeezed or TV
mic and however they had to stretch him
in the Taffy puller in order to get him
back to size uh they're probably going
to get more of the of the money unless
the other kids got incinerated but uh I
I do believe that it's a situation where
there would be payouts and then they
would move forward and Charlie would
have his Chocolate Factory at least
that's what I want to believe because I
want to believe that the Chocolate
Factory still exists after the end of
the movie forgive me for putting you
through this please from a business
perspective I should absolutely every
day of the week bring in one as a client
my family would really appreciate it
because uh he would just be a constant
source of legal work and revenue I would
hire a fleet of lawyers to deal with
everything that he has to do on a
regular basis from a moral perspective
it's really hard to work with clients
who have a very different Compass who
have a very different way of viewing the
world and and a very different way of of
seeing dangers and seeing risks and all
that he's eccentric he's he's strange
but he's Reckless and it is very
difficult to advise someone like that
and have them ignore your advice and
then still go through and make really
bad decisions I don't know there's
probably a kid in me though that would
have to say yes I would represent Willy
Wonka ad you parting is such sweet
sorrow